Hello and welcome to mCoding.
In what's currentlymy most popular video of all time,
we compared the speed of a bunch of different ways to compute sum of range n.
And a surprise to absolutely no one,
the fastest way is, of course, to use thepre-computed answer.
But to my surprise,
I received hundreds of comments and even a pull request tomy Github
saying that the formula was wrong.
All of the comments gave the same wrong answer.
Theyall suggested that this minus should be a plus.
But James, the sum of the first n numbers isn(n+1)/2.
Here's a whole Wikipedia article on it.
They're called trianglenumbers and the proof is actually very simple.
Make a triangle where the n-th row has n dots.
Double the number of dots and flip them over in order to make a rectangle.
It has height nand width n+1.
The rectangle has n*(n+1) dots. So, the triangle has halfthat.
Okay, okay. I admit that's a nice proof.
And yet, when we run the program, we see that'snot the right answer.
Try a different value, still not the right answer.
The correct formulauses the minus.
And if you want to get an int back, so even the types match, then use integerdivision.
One of these two factors is even. So, there won't be any rounding issues.
So, how is it thatwith the correct answer right in front of them,
hundreds of people not just caught the questionwrong
but all came up with the same wrong answer?
A wrong answer that could be shown to be wrongby trying even a single example.
And it's not like these commenters are dumb or trolling or somethinglike that.
They're intelligent enough to know that there's a closed-form formula for this sum.
And theoverwhelming majority of them were not trolling.
They genuinely believed that the formula waswrong.
I attribute this to what I call 'Notational Fixation'.
In simple terms, all these people knewthe formula which has an n in it.
But the n in the formula is not the n in the problem.
The nin this formula is the biggest number in the sum.
But the biggest number in this range is (n - 1).
So, if you want to use the formula with the plus, you need to plug in (n - 1), not n.
That terms this into n and this into (n - 1).
Rearranging, that's how we get the formulawith the minus sign.
In the time that I've spent teaching undergraduates,
this 'Notational Fixation'has been one of the biggest sources of errors.
It's what makes you think that this is a plot of yequals x squared.
When, in fact, it's y equals square root of x.
This is, of course, a primitive model ofthe number of xylophones over the course of years.
And it's what might make you think that the areaof this inner circle is pi * r squared.
When, in fact, it's pi * r.
Notational Fixation starts becauseit's an easy way to remember formulas and keep things straight in your head.
Always using the samenames for variables can be both helpful
as well as a great tool for communicating your ideas withothers.
If I say, a squared plus b squared equals c squared,
everybody knows I'm talking about a righttriangle.
But in the real world, problems aren't going to come to you
with their variables labeledlike they are in your textbook.
If you're worried about making mistakes due to Notational Fixation,
then here's what I recommend.
Practice scrambling all your variables.
Make an x that's a functionof f.
Call all of your variables J.
And of course, don't forget to try real examples that use goodnames and reasonable numbers.
All these things will help you see past the notation and understand themeaning.
Just remember not to leave any scrambled variables in your code, of course.
When you'recommunicating with others and with yourself in the future,
it's important to use the notationthat everyone's familiar with.
Anyway, that's all I've got.
As usual, thank you to my patrons anddonors for supporting me.
See you in the next one.